فعلا اشرس المعارك واعنف في منطقه معسكر
خانيونس وكذلك في منطقه حي الامل حيث
تتواجد قوات الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال في
هاتين المنطقتين منذ اكثر من ثمانيه ايام
وتتواجد فعليا على الارض وتقوم هناك
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بتصدي لهذا العدوان
بحيث تتصدى باطلاق قذائف مضاده للضروف
بجاه اليات الاحتلال وهناك اشتباكات ايضا
مباشره ما بين جنود الاحتلال وكذلك
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في هاتين المنطقتين
والحديث ايضا خلال الساعات الماضيه عن
اكثر من 14 شهيدا وصلوا الى مستشفيات
محافظه خانون السواء في مستشفى ناصر وكذلك
مستشفى غزه الاوروبي بعض هذه الحالات او
هذه الجثامين وصلت الى مستشفى متحلله اي
انهم قد انتش تم انتشاله انتشال من بعض
المناطق التي وصل اليها المواطنون بجهد او
جهود شخصيه يصلون الى بعض المناطق ويتم
نقل هذه الجثامين باتجاه مستشفيات محافظه
خان يونس عمليات القصف طيره الليل وحتى
هذه الساعه لم تتوقف كذلك عمليات النسف من
قبل قوات الاحتلال لمربعات سكنيه تجددت
منذ صباح هذا اليوم في اكثر من منطقه خاصه
في وسط محافظه خانيونس كان هناك قصف مدفعي
في في محيط عماره جاسر في وسط محافظه
خانيونس هناك عمليه نسف مربعات سكنيه في
منطقه التحلي ومنطقه جورج اللوت في محافظه
خان يونس اضافه الى القصف المدفعي العنيف
والكفيف في محيط مستشفى الامل التابع
لجمعيه الهال الاحمر الفلسطيني مازال هذا
المستشفى محاصرا كما هو مستشفى ناصر ايضا
محاصر لا يستطيع احد الخروج من هذا
المستشفى في حين ان مواطنين ا عدد كبير من
المواطنين من القاطنين حول مستشفى الامل
وكذلك مستشفى ناصر لجوا الى هذين
المستشفيين بحثا عن الامان خاصه في في ظل
عمليات القصف المدفعي التي تتم من قبل
قوات الاحتلال وكذلك التحذيرات التي
تطلقها قوات الاحتلال بين الحين والاخر
للمواطنين في هاتين المنطقتين بضروره
الخروج من هاتين المنطقتين والتوجه الى
منطقه المواصي باعتبارها منطقه امنه لكن
المواطنون خلال التجارب السابقه فيما
يتعلق بتعامل قوات الاحتلال مع المواطنين
الذين ينزحون باتجاه الممر الذي يعتبره
الاحتلال ممرا انسانيا الا ان هذه التجارب
كانت صعبه جدا للمواطنين حيث عمليات
اعتقال تتواصل من قبل قوات الاحتلال
لاعداد كبيره من المواطنين ويتم احتجازهم
في ظروف اعتقال صعبه عمليات تمكين وتعذيب
ايضا بالمعتقلين هذا دفع المعدم خروج الى
تلك المناطق في هذه اللحظات القصف المدف
يتجدد في المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه خانيونس
سنستمع الى هذا القصف في هذه اللحظات في
الاجزاء الشرقيه من المحافظه تحديدا في
المناطق بني سهيله وكذلك منطقه عبسان
الكبيره وعبس الجديده اضافه الى منطقه
ايضا جورج اللوت التي تتواجد خلفنا هذه
المنطقه ويتم فيها بين الحين والاخر
عمليات نسف من قبل قوات الاحتلال في في
هذه المناطق محافظه فانوس من اقصى الشرق
الى اقصى الغرب هي محاصره من قبل قوات
الاحتلال وتمنع حركه المواطنين في اكثر من
منطقه ومن يتحرك في بعض المناطق يتم
استهدافه من قبل اليات الاحتلال وكذلك من
طائرات الاحتلال سواء المسيره او حتى
الطائرات الحربيه لتقصف منازل مواطنين في
اكثر من منطقه في خانيونس القصف المدفعي
في هذه اللحظات عنيف في المنطقه الشرقيه
نستمع الى هذا الاف الى هذه الانفجارات في
هذه اللحظات حيث تستهدف قوات الاحتلال
منازل المواطنين في المناطق الشرقيه
للمحافظه سواء في منطقه البخاري ومنطقه
بني سهيله كذلك منطقه خزاعه وكذلك بلده
عبسان الكبيره وعبس الجديده قوات الاحتلال
خلال الساعات الماضيه كثفت من غاراتها
وكذلك كثفت عمليات القصف المدفعي الذي
يستمر ويتواصل حتى هذه اللحظه في محافظه
خن يونس اشكرك جزيل
الشكر اسماعيل ابو عمر مراسلنا من خان
يونس